today I have a 2011 Hyundai Sonata with
a smart entry so we're going to go ahead
and program the process is very similar
to the Genesis the only difference is
the emergency start port is not by the
shifter it is inside on rest
it's kind of hard to see revoke it right
here folks
you can you hear those and once again
he's reading this across in there
and obviously the car doesn't work
that's keen on detective okay when I go
to a Hyundai obviously USA proximity and
go buy a vehicle Sonata 2011 look at the
condition itself enter
okay we're in this time when and right
away their locations will take more than
one try but so far so good Center
special functions in a letter go head
intellect keys programs becoming a key
for November II you can see this two
keys memory this enter and clear program
products enter which you know means when
I raise all the processes in the memory
and program hours okay okay we're clear
check marks recognition off insert king
is already in there and then measure
myself entered okay we need a security
code we already have one second follow
it once again it's very important that
you have good power to this card many
people have jump oxes but to be honest I
don't like them because they don't
generate energy they store it but it
didn't generate if you have you jump
cables from your band to the car you're
always sure that you have good power
because the car is running and feeding
power to the car that is not okay so our
code is 741 over here seven four one
five seven six five other six
okay so therefore one specimen six
checkmark
okay back to exit or enter the program
next piece at this point you can switch
our process press enter and it will keep
added or if you only have one you want
to be done just press back procedure
complete let's enter okay and when I go
to keys program to check how many keys
we have in the memory and as you can see
we have one key so it means our
programming works let's enter this point
you can turn off your machine okay let's
take the rocks out of the just go
ahead and pull it up let's write
right here if you work and obviously
step on the brake
that's very important that we have our
jumper cables hooked up of this car
because the battery is really really low
[Music]
okay let's try it one more time
okay the keys program you can see right
here turn the button presses card
everything comes on and obviously young
lock button works a problem right now
just a battery clean too low that's why
the car is not cranking but uh just to
show you that you're going to have even
with good power into the car it's not
good enough to clean the car so that's
why I prefer always trouble cables to
jump boxes in order to program ha
especially procs keys and now does it
keys done you know it was pretty simple